après coup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi mon accoutrement en quoi je
suis madame à castanet falek françois
non voilà un gars ménages ambassade à
6,1 macgyver savez y perdre
on est tous déguisés on a les 4 8 ans
tom cruise ouais ça se voit comme guns
ah ouais ouais ouais battre ça se voit
et mais ça te va bien je tâcherai j'aime
bien ce petit jeu pour iphone je suis
pas en reine des neiges que c'est un
petit peu on va accueillir tout de suite
le premier c'est jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
gilles et isabelle
[Applaudissements]
houngbo
ah ah
alors je vous le dis à laives un petit
avantage c'est qu'elle avait déjà la
moustache
[Musique]
j'ai entendu ce que tu as dit son ami
facebook et l'opposition mais pas du
tout amalgame mais je sais que j'étais
amoureuse de lui on me reymond a votre
avis il en quoi raymond c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bois de boulogne première fois c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
on va passer maintenant
vous avez envie d'avoir de voir
quelqu'un de sexy oui allez celui-là on
a envie d'en voir une autre le très sexy
mme c'est à vous dire je suis comme un
fou depuis tout à l'heure je la vois
c'est un truc de ouf je fais georges la
regarde pas mais je suis comme un ouf
sur elle daniel moreau
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
et on va terminer avec bien sûr que
celles qui montent y sera à votre avis
en quoi sabrine comme la régie c'est
aller dans sabrina
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
allez